my goodness what is happening Sam Alman
has resigned as the CEO of open Ai and
we'll talk about this new AI tool too
which will be the future of Music
Creation according to deep mind but
firing Sam Alman really why everything
seemed so good this isn't news that you
expect to hear after the first open AI
developer conference where they
announced gp4 Turbo and perhaps the
first AI App Store in a historic moment
and more and in the meantime work on GPT
5 is also underway they also created GPT
bot a WebCrawler as a preparation for
gp5 open AI also needs to raise more
money than the 10 billion they have from
Microsoft and work is underway on that
too and at that moment the news just
drops out of the sky some old man has
been asked by the board to step down wow
and what happened then was absolute
pandemonium dear fellow Scholars this is
two-minute papers with Dr
Caro so what happened then well shortly
after Greg Brockman co-founder and
president of open AI also resigned and
that's not all then shortly after three
highlevel researchers also resigned
clearly there are big disagreements
within the company as to how they should
proceed what I hear is that one side
would like to take a slower more aligned
approach while the other is interested
in moving more quickly it is very
difficult to say which is the right
approach especially in the presence of
this pace of progress that you see here
on two minute papers sometimes you see a
paper that is kind of okay but a bit
like a toy like the dolly to text to
image Ai and then one or two more Works
down the line Dolly 3 an absolute
Powerhouse drops and that's not all open
AI is a nonprofit entity as it has been
created by its Founders but it is a
for-profit entity too now I hear you
asking doctor what is going on here how
does this happen you see both are true
open AI is a nonprofit entity that owns
The for-profit Entity and the board of
directors controls the top level clearly
there are differences in opinion whether
that is a good thing or not is open AI
going to become a big trillion doll
company or is it going to be a small and
Scrappy startup with these Miracle AI
systems differences in opinion in there
too I am sure now in the meantime
Microsoft major investor in open AI they
are likely as surprised by this as we
are but they have billions of dollars
invested there and they are not happy
especially because of what happened next
next Alman said that he's ready for the
next venture presumably with his
co-founder Greg Brockman and a bunch of
researchers by his side I expected that
an announcement will be made about the
next chapter for them and then another
bombshell news appears presumably due to
the wishes of investors and Microsoft
Alman is in talks again to be reinstated
as CEO just about a day later so what
could happen here well option one if
that happens Alman would be back and
would likely be way more powerful than
before also I can't imagine Microsoft
not asking for at least a board seat or
perhaps an entirely new board may be
created or option too otherwise Sam
might create a competitor to open Ai and
I am sure there will be investors who
are eager to be a part of it but wait it
is still not done the talks have already
started and Alman was ambivalent about
coming back not so sure a key deadline
was missed which may trigger the mass
resignation of even more scientists at
open AI so what is going to happen now
who really knows the story is still
ongoing so far this is absolute
pandemonium there are likely intense and
I mean intense talks in the situation
room right now and in the meantime Deep
Mind showcased an amazing new Music
Creation AI where you can do as little
as just hum a song and it will come to
life as a sexophone solo or any kind of
music you wish it even creates music in
the style of popular artists wait for it
fellow Scholars only a few select
artists who have agreed to this program
these will be typically 30 second song
Snippets to be used in YouTube shorts so
you don't have to listen to the same few
songs that dominate The Market at the
time instead new stuff all the time
really cool now interestingly these
songs will also be digitally watermarked
it is completely inaudible you will not
hear anything but a computer will be
able to detect it as a piece of AI
generated content interestingly this
Watermark will also survive if someone
converts or Rec compresses the file into
a different format I am happy to hear
that we are starting to figure out how
to Mark AI created content on the
internet for music and images there is
already great progress on this loving it
once again the papers that you see here
in these videos are coming to life what
a time to be alive note that the sources
for hopefully everything that I said
here are available in the video
description weights and biases
experiment tracking model evaluation and
production monitoring for your deep
learning products and llm apps it is the
best everyone is using it try it out now
at wb. me/ ERS or click the link in the
description below